la procureure générale hélène magliano
de la cour d'appel de dijon a décidé de
demander la réouverture du dossier de
l'affairé grégory
il s'agit d'effectuer une recherche
d'empreintes génétiques à partir
d'éléments de salif qui se trouveraient
sur un morceau de teint coller à l'une
des lettres du tristement célèbre
corbeau on se souvient de la mort de cet
enfant en octobre 84 près de lépanges
dans les vosges cette décision de
réouverture dont les parents et les
grands parents de la victime sont à
l'origine est un ultime moyen
d'investigation pour tenter de connaître
la vérité sur la mort de grégory
villemin commentaires valérie ermite
avec sébastien irwin jérôme soûlard les
progrès scientifiques concernant l'adn
et les empreintes génétiques
constitue-t-il un élément nouveau
après plus de quatre mois de réflexion
hélène magliano procureur général à
dijon vient de répondre par
l'affirmative en demandant la
réouverture du dossier grégory cette
piste nouvelle nous pouvait pas mon sens
être négligée car s'il expertises adn
s'avérer positive
eh bien elle pourrait contribuer je
crois d'une manière à la fois sérieuse
et utiles à la recherche de la vérité
dans un crime dont la gravité apparaître
à tout le monde et qui je le rappelle à
ce jour est demeuré impuni
c'est sur la recherche d' adn sur ce
demi timbre que repose l'espoir d'une
éventuelle vérité judiciaire
un timbre collé en 1983 sur l'une des
trois lettres de menaces envoyées à la
famille villemin
pour moi c'est une grande et vainement
important parce que
qui identifie le corbeau ne sera pas
loin d'identifier le sa salle du petit
caux après l'assassinât de bernard
laroche et le non lieu de christine
villemin
le dossier grégory semblait
définitivement clos l'adn comme moyen
d'identifier le corbeau est peut-être la
dernière piste exploitable par la
justice malgré les réserves scientifique
de l'expert consulté à cause notamment
des nombreuses manipulations qu'a subi
ce timbre les parents du petit grégory
expriment leur satisfaction
une immense satisfaction et ce poids
incommensurable de parvenir à laroche à
la manifestation de la vérité
un souci aussi le souci que nous
puissions à nouveau connaître
éventuellement certains débordements
médiatiques tout à fait détestable que
nous avions vu en son temps et le couple
villemin dans ma plaie à la sérénité
c'est maintenant à la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de dijon
de trancher elle seule peut décider de
rouvrir le dossier grégory